all right y'all I'm still here keeping
up with my social distancing with my
family here in Montana this hour though
we're gonna be celebrating my new single
I dare you that I actually got to record
in six different languages which was
really a dream come true for me the song
is about love in all its forms in the
face of adversity you know choosing to
love instead of fear I'm proud that the
singers from all over the world sang
with me on this track I love all the
different languages I actually listen to
those more than the English version but
we're singing in their native languages
and we're so excited that we actually
have them on Zune
today we have blast from Espana we have
Lucia from Morocco we have Carolyn from
Germany and we also have Maya from
Israel how y'all doing hey Kelly
well okay guys we're all here officially
um boss like what are you doing like
right now like how are you handling the
quarantine yeah I'm good a few things
before the state homework I was visiting
my mom and I could not back home to my
dream and Here I am I'm good I'm happy
because I found myself again I can I can
see the day all the old pictures and
beautiful awesome
Oh what about you Carolyn what are you
doing in Germany how are you hanging
yeah I'm doing good I'm staying home I
love Chris and yeah I'm trying to make
the best of the situation we are all in
yeah and I try to focus on some staff
that snaps I'm done at home like
cleaning up my closet oh my god
organized everything yeah most
importantly I have next time to write
some songs from a band jazz piano yeah I
think it's kind of good to stay at home
now and yeah all right well what about
you cause you know what
Fuzzy's what are you what are you doing
right now you're in Canada right yes
thankfully I've been doing really well
and I've been keeping busy working
around these conditions and making home
and I even got to make a music video
from home which was a new experience
oh my god I've just been praying you
know for all the lives lost and I just
hope everybody's safe seriously
all right well Maya what's up with you
how are you hanging well actually I'm
now in a show okay like yours girl we
are yeah we are shooting right now I'm
so excited that it's not here you know
because okay I quit you know the song is
about daring to love instead of fear so
what's the most selfless thing that
someone has done for you that really
kind of stands out for you plus you can
go a few days ago I remember that I had
a problem with an L computer here at
home and I asked for somebody to help me
on Instagram and a boy sent me a typic
message and we were repairing that pink
together holding it yes it was great now
I have a new friend and a new computer
yeah and sapless is what my mother did
to me and we went through some tough
times after my father left us and yeah
so she worked she she was always working
so hard to make my dreams and wishes
come true and because she's the reason
why I have a chance to become a musician
and yeah without her I wouldn't be where
I am now so I'm yeah I'm very thankful
for that
that's so cool we have a very similar
story after you just said that so what
about you cause it kind of the same
thing but both my parents have been like
very obviously very selfless and I think
that I think that the love you know your
parents or your parents or whoever it
may be and you know that they don't
expect anything in return it's like it's
kind of scary but it's also a very pure
feeling and
I I honestly Oh everything to them and
to my family and your parents sound
amazing I remember you talking about in
the studio for a very lucky kid that's
so cool
you're not a case the kid to me what
about you since I've I've been a mother
it's it's it's amazing it's like to see
at a low person loves you just free love
with nowhere even in this horrible
situation think or honor that's all the
kids are home and they are suffering
from you know doing nothing or study at
home please to eat just selfless is like
okay mommy just you know just for you to
be happy and for me it's the most
incredible thing just to to appreciate
free love you know with with no I would
be like this after this corner yeah well
thank you guys so much
the song is very meaningful to me the
project is very meaningful for me and
it's even more meaningful that y'all
elevated it so much with your languages
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going